hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast pre integy no typing for
pharmacogenomic risk establishing a
benchmark I am Christina mahalik of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
our metrics at the metrics Aparna thermo
fisher scientific is a pioneer in
microarray technology and a leader in
genomic analysis at the metrics develops
and provides innovative technologies
than enable multiplex and perineal
analysis of biological systems at the
cell protein and gene level facilitating
the rapid translation of results into
biology for a better world we are proud
to be pardoned thermo fisher scientific
helping to advance our mission to enable
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer for more information
please visit at the metrics com we do
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window we
will try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the side window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit the
problem through the grain Q&A button
found in the lower left corner this is
an educational webinar and this offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click
on the c/e button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of taming your
credits now I would like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Ulrich vocal
professor of pediatrics medicine and
physiology chief section and genomic
pediatrics and department of pediatrics
Medical College of Wisconsin dr. Albert
broeckel graduated from medical school
at the University Heidelberg Germany
after residency training in internal
medicine and cardiology he carried out
postdoctoral research at the Medical
College of Wisconsin he joined the
faculty at MCW in two thousand and is
currently professor in the department of
pediatrics and the chief of the section
of genomic pediatrics his research
focuses on identification of genes for
complex diseases understanding gene
functions and application of genetics
and genomics and clinical practice his
work combines clinical applications with
functional genome analysis using induced
pluripotent stem cells for disease
modeling and risk prediction dr. Burkle
is the scientific director of a CLIA cat
certified clinical laboratory which
conducts clinical testing for structural
chromosomal abnormalities as well as
pharmacogenomic testing I will now turn
it over to dr. Buerkle for his
presentation
you
you
great well thank you
much for the kind introduction is my
great pleasure to have the opportunity
to talk a little bit about the work
we're doing in my lap and you know we've
been focusing in pharmacogenetics and
clinical implementation of
pharmacogenetics for many years so I'm
very happy and I'm very glad that I can
give this presentation as it was
mentioned before if you have any
questions please you know type entities
this question is doing that presentation
I will also give this presentation for
our startup company which focuses on a
pre-emptive pharmacogenetic testing our
prd diagnostics which is a spin-out
after Medical College of Wisconsin and
my laboratory and so just a conflict of
interest done we already spin it out the
Medical College of Wisconsin and part of
the data generated here in this
presentation was generated with early
access program and that was provided by
a few metrics so I want to tell you a
little bit about pharmacogenetics and
how we look at pharmacogenetics in the
context of providing care to patients
adult patients and also pediatric
patients and I'll walk you through some
of the examples how we implement it in
how we are contributing to the
implementation of clinical
pharmacogenetic testing a pre-emptive
setting so when you give you a little
background around pharmacogenetics in
general it's well established that the
response to drugs in patient is actually
variable not at all patients who receive
a drug response in the same way and the
number of factors actually contribute to
this obviously this is the patient
phenotype itself the age to gender body
mass index diabetes and so on the
characteristics of the disease there's
also in many cases it is actually not
just one drug a patient received their
multiple drugs and so in many cases we
actually have drug-drug interaction
which actually affects to response to to
the variational we observe in a patient
and then obviously the genetic risk
factors in a Jag background plays a role
which affects then the the response and
the
active not a fire truck and this is
really the aerial of pharmacogenetics
and all these things really combined all
these three major factors really
determine the variation in the response
and patience and I want to talk a little
bit about in particular pharmacogenetics
and how we can use pharmacogenetics to
tailor and provide a detailer treatment
provide better treatment to patients so
if you think about pharmacogenetics
right now in many cases the clinical
testing right now is very much drug
driven we have a particular drug it's
very much candidate gene driven it's a
single drug we know for example a drug
and we know the eda target on the
receptor or the enzyme which metabolizes
too drunk and make dis effective and and
so we're analyzing one drug combined
with one cheating and in many ways this
is also then very reactive so physicians
decides to decide to prescribe a drug
and we order a genetic test in many
cases that will drive then the way how
we chose our the dough's the drug or
what type of truck we would like to like
to use now if you think about this in
general so how pharmacogenetics has been
around for quite some time you know you
can ask the question so how how many
drugs are really out there where
pharmacogenetics could actually I should
be used in determining which drug is
most effective and because you know I
think there is well established now that
there are a number of well-established
examples that pharmacogenetic drugs and
relationship to drugs actually maximizes
the drug efficiency and also is able to
reduce adverse events in a recent review
if we just look for example at all the
fda-approved drugs if you look at the
lower bottom but seven percent of all
the about a thousand two hundred drugs
which are currently approved there is
actually evidence for the
pharmacogenetic genes actually affect
the the response so you can look at
obviously the number of drugs but you
could also look at the number of
prescriptions which are actually filled
in the United States with roughly about
four billion about eighteen percent of
the filled prescription in the
have actionable are associated with
actionable pharmaco cheese and so if you
look at all this combined we have about
800 actionable genetic variants which
are linked to the dosing and where we
have guidelines from the FDA on this
fda-approved proof drugs so it's not a
small number of genes and so on that you
know it is really a significant
component of this the other way how you
can look at this is obviously and you
can say you know if we look at
particular genes which have been linked
to pharmacogenetics you know what's the
frequency in different and at different
populations and because of genetics and
genetic variants have different
frequencies in different ethnic groups
here this is an example of a reason to
our review run pharmacogenetics but here
are the number of genes here on the
bottom and number list of genes and you
can see that depending on the gene and
the ethnic group there in some for some
of these drugs is a very high frequency
of potentially actionable high risk
genes high-risk genotypes for these
forests bigotry so all in all the the
number of drugs and the frequency of
variants for particular groups is
actually reasonably reasonably high
we're going to the next slide if we
think about the deceased spectrum where
this where pharmacogenetics can play a
role it basically covers all different
diseases so we can look at we see a lot
of examples in psychiatry and
neurological diseases oncology has a
number of significant number of genes
and drugs which have been described and
in particular in oncology at a number of
of genes and relevant genes or drugs is
continuously growing but with also it
covers the air for Texas diseases pain
cardiovascular disease GI and diabetic
disease it really covers the whole
spectrum of all diseases where are in
our main diseases where we're really
focusing on one of the questions we
continuously get is in
this is actually really does it make
sense from an economic point of view to
do pharmacogenetic testing is this
really cost-effective and I just want to
pinpoint you to one particular article
which was recently published in this
year which looked at the evidence
whether pharmacogenetic testing in
relation to particular genes in
particular tracks it is really cost
effective and there's this video
reviewed very comprehensively the
current literature basically concludes
that they identified very robust
evidence by the cost-effectiveness of
genotyping prior to the treatment for a
number of quite commonly use drugs not
just very rare gospel commonly used
drugs and obviously additional research
is really necessary to refer to expand
on on this but it really already builds
the foundation that it is actually in
fact cost effective so when we think
about now clinically how pharmacogenetic
testing is done pharmacogenetic testing
has been around for a long time and I
gave you all this background here about
pharmacogenetic testing it might be
actually you know surprising there to
say that you know for many drugs where
this is recommended or where we have
really actually strong evidence that
pharmacogenetic testing is is an
official this testing is isn't it not
done and so in my presentation looking
pinpoint to some of the beyond the the
reasons why this is the case so but
currently if we think about clinical
approach investing in many cases this is
really just done that you know I
precision prescribes a wants to
prescribe a particular drug it's very
much driven by a drug very much
candidate gene driven you have a drunk
we have a particular gene and we're
really combining just one single gene
and one single rocket in many cases this
is very reactive so we want to prescribe
a drug we decided on the drunk and we
nearly recognize that you know we
actually need this genetic test if you
order the genetic tests and and in many
cases then you know you have to wait and
if you can't wait then you sometimes
prescribed o'clock with
pharmacogenetic testing and so on this
background here you know we really
thought about this how can we you know
make pharmacogenetic testing and you
know what what how can we make
pharmacogenetic testing more widely
acceptable and what is the type of
infrastructure and approach what we
actually could do to really improve the
treatment and really bring
pharmacogenetic more into clinical
practice and so if you think about all
the genes not really all the drugs what
I told you where we have this guidance
or where we have really strong evidence
it's really a very limited set of
established genes and established a
variance and the other really important
thing to keep in mind our to mention is
that a lot of the genes which use for
pharmacogenetic testing are not linked
to just one particular drug but actually
are linked to either a group of glutes
or actually a very number of large
number of drugs because these genes are
for example and and enzymes in the liver
which affect the metabolism and so a lot
of different drugs actually use a
limited set of these these enzymes and
so with that if you have one particular
genetic test that actually becomes
applicable to a large number of drugs
here and in addition to that obviously
if you think about this then with this
limited number of set if you do then
that's pretty inherent to any genetic
testing if you do pharmacogenetic
testing these results because it
obviously does change over time the
pharmacogenetic testing results really
retain their relevance so if you test a
particular patient you get the results
and you can determine that then you know
obviously these the results for this
really retain of relevance you know for
for a lifetime and so if you combine all
this and you really think about that you
know it becomes pretty illogical to
think and and and conclude that really
pharmacogenetic testing could be a prime
example where pre-emptive testing
actually really would make sense so if a
patient a individual has all the
information available on these
pharmacogenetic genes I mean you have to
readily accessible you really can access
this now at the time when you decide to
prescribe a particular time so this is
kind of some of the background here and
some of the concepts why we think that
pre-emptive testing in the current time
actually makes sense and is a very
attractive approach so there are a
number of different initiatives which
really started out potentially as a
research project but really bringing
this into the clinic and implement a
pre-emptive pharmacogenetic testing my
lab we have been working for many years
now with st. Jude's Children's Hospital
in Memphis and we collaborate on a
project it's called peach and four kids
and it's really focusing on a click
implementation for pharmacogenetics in
patients at st. Jude's Children's
Hospital and so we experience what we
learned is very much in collaboration
with st. Jude's Children's Hospital you
can go to the link if you're interested
more in this project so the goal of this
and the disability idea is that if we do
put up the pharmacogenetic testing
obviously we were interested and you
need to develop a platform a clinical
testing platform which allows us to
analyze very comprehensively the number
of number of genes we need to develop
consensus guidelines how these genes and
the results are getting interpreted
obviously initially has it started out
of the research project and we could
have continued to collect data you know
we recruit patients and families and
then the ultimate goal is to take these
results from the clinical
pharmacogenetic testing very
comprehensively and integrate this into
the medical record so that the
information is accessible to physicians
who want to and want to prescribe a
particular drug and so I just want to
give you one example for one particular
gene but
you know in terms of the complexity what
goes into a testing from the actual
genotyping to the interpretation and
obviously when we started with a DNA
sample you can you know you're just
looking at one particular gene cyp2d6
you know we obviously look at the
genotypes itself the genotypes I then
get translated in hello types as we
group not only one single variant but
multiple gene variants to help low types
that then gets translated to a
particular diplo type in this case here
and based on a diplomat we need to then
translate this into the bone called
metabolizer status so what is the
activity of this particular enzyme and
then obviously in a you can deduct from
that that you know the enzyme activity
then determines you know how we want but
this particular and how this affects a
particular drug down the road and so if
you learn it for example I particular
metabolizer that for example could mean
that if you can't metabolize a cheat off
your own metabolized itchy that you
should either you just want drug or you
shouldn't use this drug so it's not only
what i want to say here is not only that
we have to analyze a pretty good gene
get the results but there's a whole many
many more steps which really are
necessary in the interpretation of
pharmacogenetics until we get to the
point that we have a interpretation and
then a recommendation for a particular
drug here so let me start with on the
genotyping itself so over the last few
years we as we've been looking looked at
a analog DNA analysis platform from
pharmacogenetics for pre-emptive testing
which is very comprehensive so we were
one of a few groups who developed and
establish the ethyl metrics d met plus
platform solution as a clinical tests
and it's a very comprehensive genotyping
platform has about a thousand nine
hundred the markers on there about two
hundred thirty pharmacogenetic be
relevant genes and translates these
genes so i showed you in a previous line
3 star alleles
and allows you to analyze these samples
and then get all themselves for most of
these variants the platform itself was
established quite a few years ago and so
very recently after a few metrics and
thermo Fisher now launched the second
generation and update of this platform
called pharmacol scan and really the
idea there is that extends the demon
plus platform and really is not much
broader and really incorporates the
results of the more recent you know
publication and scientific evidence as
it grew over the years and now this
platform has you know you can see this
here substantial increase in when I look
at about a 4,600 markers in about 1000
culture 1,200 jeans again translates to
these these star alleles so just I want
to review with you some of the content
of the the new pharmacol scan you get
early access and we established be the
characteristics of off the platform
collected a lot of experience with this
knowledge without the the results not
what you can do it and show me some
examples for particular genes the change
itself are basically accumulate all
information from a number of different
resources one of them is see pic this is
the clinical pharmacogenetic
implementation consortium the other one
is pharmgkb which is the pharmacogenomic
knowledge database those are both
resources which curate pharmacokinetic
information and also then in particular
in the case for see pic information how
you implement and guidelines on how to
implement the results or pharmacogenetic
testing so here just a link to both of
the side sea pig on information that
consortium if you want to go follow this
link or pharmgkb are really two key you
know resources for pharmacogenetics if
you're interested in following this
further going deeper into this so here's
just roughly a overview of the of the
different genes which are you know on
the on the pharmacol scanner a song
number of see pic jeans here these are
all genes where we have guidelines for
the clear implementation how the
genotyping translates to a particular
gene how you implement then the
interpretation that is disappear you
reviewed publications and you can obtain
this article on a secret website there
are number of genes mainly on the cips
where we call these haplotypes the start
alleles and I want to mention also that
a number of genes that which is really
very important for this platform
actually analyze copy number variation
structural abnormalities and you can see
this year on the the right right site so
it's very comprehensive platform again
the content of this the essay itself
when you walk you through here real
quick is a four-day SI so we basically
start with P na followed by an
amplification airy fragmentation on the
second day in a precipitation and a
resuspension in a day three
hybridization is a typical standard
array based methodologies for genotyping
in a day for elongation and they're
scanning of off the trip itself for the
protocol on the right bottom you can see
the the hands on time so overall it's a
pretty straightforward SI performed
really well and on day five the the key
thing here is that as I told you perform
we not only had the genotype but we
actually you know provide a lot of
interpretation with this and so there is
a analysis suite which actually allows
you to perform this this analysis to
translate this into star alleles so let
me show you just a few examples here how
the the output you know how could you
get from from the from the software here
and you can see here for example here it
is it's just one variant work you see
the clustering for the homozygote Leo
and heterozygous allele so you can see
here how we get to the particular
genotype here is a overall quality
control quality control particularly
clinical setting is very important so
call rate
needs to be typing mother to hearing
again summary reports on the on the test
here this is again here an example of
the snip clustering you can see your
different genotypes here you can pick
one particular gene and and so in the
next slide here we'll look at this so I
told you before some of the genes we
explained a role here in
pharmacogenetics we have copy number
variation so you either have
duplications or deletions of the gene
that you can think about that you know
if you have a deletion of a particular
gene and just for example enzyme you
have done you know reduced activity or
no activities on the analysis of copy
number gracious is critical for calling
the the correct genotype not only in a
snip level but also in the copy number
level and so as you can see here it
allows for the analysis of copy number
variation or for example a or deletions
here in for this particular gene that
would be for example cyp2d6 a number of
company ova probes included in this this
analysis the other thing which is
available in this platform here is the
analysis of HL a class 1 and class 2
here are some examples that are normal
examples were HLA genotypes and and
haplotypes actually contribute to the
risk so that is an improvement compared
to the previous demon plus platform as
well and so the first question in our
you know we ever start a new platform
particularly when one translate when you
want to translate this into clinical
care is really the the performance in
the characteristics and so I'll show you
here one slide where we in from our
early access program so we typed samples
which are with established genotypes
here and we looked at the concordance
rate and we looked at the call rate and
the pass rate and if you just look here
at the bottom here at the most
importantly st the concordance with
samples and the previously genotype
results for overall as well as for the
heterozygotes and you can see that the
concordance from from the previous
platform to the common down pharmacol
scan platform is over ninety-nine
percent so we're overall we were quite
excited to see that this dislike
recurrence rate both for samples from
from Corey Ellis on internal samples
which we collected here so the other
thing and this is a resource for the
pharmacogenetic testing community here i
want to draw a little bit of tension to
this the center of Disease Control
actually has a program and that's called
a genetic testing reference material
coordination program or get RM very long
name and to the goal of this project is
that we establish a set of DNA samples
with known genotypes pharmacogenetic
genotypes and and so this set of DNA
samples from satellites are available
from corey also clinical apps are
interested in in establishing this they
can actually order the cell lines for
proficiency testing in establishing the
DSA in their lab and so we used
pharmacol scan on the samples and we
actually contributed with teammate plus
this program number of different testing
platforms here just a list of other the
testing platforms which contributed to
this program in the pharmacogenetic area
community genotypes to to the to the
website and and so we also used the
pharmacol scan platform now to genotype
this reference samples and will provide
the genotyping results on these samples
for the pharmacol scan were a platform
to to this website for comparisons and
so just looking at this very cursory we
started to do
careful comparisons is that if we
analyze the samples Buddha and if they
have a high call rate here over the car
it on these reference samples was over
ninety-nine percent as you can see here
and if we look at the concordance 10
between pharmacol scan and email for
this reference FD&C identical coins was
extremely high i also want to pinpoint
then that you know selecting quality
control parameters is important and we
have for example if we have samples here
where the quality cut off the kulluk was
not met these samples that have lower
lower concurrences and then obviously
should not pass it in a clinical testing
environment so that as control here as
well so overall so we have here the the
pharmacogenetic testing platform to be
very comprehensive I think is a
prerequisite and really then the ID here
is if we think about implementing
pharmacogenetic testing you know i'll
start with them the physicians here we
artists the tests we do in our clear
improved from a quick lap we form the
testing reform the genotyping to the
data translation and then this is the
next step here if it comes to the
interpretation not only to the
particular haplotype with diplo type and
also then the interpretation under
metabolizer status for a particular gene
and then with these results it goes back
to the implementation to the physician
then for the interpretation have as it
related for particular a for a
particular drug or drug combination so
really this is kind of to circle recetas
and and so to the last point then when
we have these results you know what's
really important is that we take the
genotyping results and interpretation
metabolized status and really um you
know i think because pharmacogenetic is
so complex and there are so many drugs
out there and in the interpretation
really of so you know really needs and
requires a lot of expertise but it is
really important that we really provide
the
the additional decision support around
this and I think here this is where in
particular the integration into it EMR
becomes absolutely critical and show me
some examples which was an example which
were developed at st. Jude's in an EMR
sirna as a platform to really help
physicians manage pharmacogenetic
information and and so here's just one
particular example for TPMT which is
used as a genetic test for entire
purines and so let's assume you want to
prescribe a precision wants to prescribe
this and we don't have any genetic
results done in the EMR you can have a
decision support pretest warning that
you know genetic pharmacogenetic testing
is really recommended and we don't have
any results and really direct the
physician and the ordering physician Joe
basically order this fabric will take
tests before you'll prescribe a
particular drug now if you actually have
pre-emptive pharmacogenetic testing you
can actually incorporate this already
and indeed in medical record and
decision support here as well and really
you know let's say for example you have
certain results here you can actually
add this into the into a problem list
and so that the results are really
available for example if you have a
patient was a poor metabolizer for a
particular gene and then you can develop
this decision support to link these
high-risk genotypes with drug ordering
or prescribing information and so here's
one example let's say for example you
have the information on go back to
cyp2d6 and you do want to prescribe a
drug which is linked to this particular
gene to the particular metabolizer
status the result of the family
testing then really the decision support
in an EMR can be very handy to basically
you know gift physicians of warring say
like you know what maybe you really want
to consider this because this fellow
fortunate testing is currently available
so this is this post 10 and test
infrastructure and I think with this I
think if we really think about you know
some of the hurdles what we have in
pharmacogenetic testing is really the
interpretation the complexities around
interpretation being able to automate
that I think it's going to be a key step
to really allow us to make
pharmacogenetic testing much more
available in the clinic and make this
much more straightforward so we've been
doing not only was in truth a couple
other groups we've been doing
pre-emptive pharmacogenetic testing
there are a number of other
organizations out there as well who have
programs and birth who do
pharmacogenetic a pre-emptive testing
and overall from our experience you know
I just want to summarize here obviously
the pros of the advantages if you have
this testing available basically and in
our opinion i think in my personal
opinion the key I want the advantages
that you know really if you have a
genetic test readily available you have
these tests whenever a critical decision
important is if he needs to be made so
do i prescribed drug a or do i
prescribed kirkby or should i pezzi
avoid drugs see at all so those are
really you know decisions which are made
at the time and and so basically having
available at tropicana testing and
information just prevents the delay of
like ordering a test waiting for the
result and in many cases you guess you
can't do this you don't want to wait
until you have a genetic test and then
so I think that really is the main the
bench um the other key thing here is and
this is really very much in a technical
side if you think about you have to
analyze a lot of different genes and it
brings in the medical record what are
the concerns we always had is that you
know is this really expensive you know
we can't really afford that
it doesn't just make you know this
really kind you can't really overcome
this and I think one of the they're
really and not just in general one of
the really great you know improvements
we hand over the last few years
particularly in a DNA analysis platform
is did tremendous amount of reduction a
tremendous reduction in cost for
genotyping and DNA analysis and I think
with this really very comprehensive
pharmacogenetic testing comes very much
into the realm of that you can do this
and a lot of patients can afford this
and be the cost of these these gene
panels becomes very very feasible and
compared to even just a few years ago of
the cost if you compared to the cost of
one particular cheats and then again you
know I think the the improvement in
learning and implementing EMR and the
decision support in an EMR I think this
really becomes much more might be
acceptable and so I think this is also a
very critical component with this and
what we see in general is that if you
hear functioning results available if
these are available to physicians and
you have the decision support then it
actually increases also the acceptance
of pharmacogenetics there is still a
hurdle here despite recommendations
despite the regulated by the FDA and
guidelines there is still a lot of girls
here to implement pharmacogenetics and I
think pre-emptive ourselves available
decision support I think really we've
seen is that it really increases the
acceptance for physicians introduces dia
the overall girl the pharmacogenetic
testing obviously some of the challenges
what we've experienced how long is that
the genotyping itself you know if you
really think about this the cost came
down your chin your timing self it's
really the easy part it's really the
implementation which is still critical
it's still a challenge and then it
starts with basically everybody who's
involved in in in the whole whole
process and so it's not all your
positions that's also pharmacists nurses
the patients and so this really needs a
very comprehensive approach in these
discussions with the healthcare
organization with physicians to to
understand their their their needs and
so if I could summarize some of the
will our it's just some of the key
points here what we're certainly going
to continue to learn as we implement
different genes as we implement new
guidelines as we expand now from the
open country even more comprehensive
genotyping platform and our experience
implementation is always site-specific
it really as I mentioned before it's
very much driven by clinical needs by
the patient population and by the
overall interest of healthcare
organizations if you want to implement
this it's always important to capture
opinion leaders in your organization to
really drive this forward and look at
the the needs you know the in your
organization's education becomes key
collaboration with physicians and really
the continued evaluation of the
scientific evidence is also a key
component and all this really as I
mentioned the forum really requires a
multidisciplinary team so it needs to
clinical lab needs the pharmacy needs
pharmacogenetic experts it needs the
physician and it also requires the input
by medical records EMR and clinical
informatics so with that let me
summarize that you know we think that
pre-emptive pharmacogenetic testing
nearly offers a lot of clinically
relevant and important advantages for
the implementation of pharmacogenetics
in the clinical care as we move to
ng'ambi pharmacol scanners and more
comprehensive genotyping platform we
think that this really it's a very
cost-effective way to generate
pharmacogenetic information which builds
the baseline for the integration into
EMR and the more intelligent prescribing
practice on the analysis software is
obviously key you know that really is
important as this translates the Apple
times in a diplomat Koecher this is
often complex for not one genius as
varies between all the different genes
and and so this is really
he that is really wrong curated and as I
said you know previously we will
actually generate and provide the
provider generated genotyping results on
these reference samples would provide
cdc website for farmer percent as a
resource to the scientific and clinical
testing community and finally let me
mentioned that our company actually
offers this collective pharmacogenetic
testing and services and consulting
around clinical from a low genetic
implementation and so with that this has
been an effort from many many
individuals for for a number of years
now particularly my my lab research and
clinical lab here at the Medical College
of Wisconsin we had very strong support
and we appreciate the support biometrics
and the people that are prd Diagnostics
as well as my collaborators at st.
Jude's Children's Hospital and at the
CDC and with that I hope I could give
you an overview of our approach and some
of the concepts and ideas around
clinical testing for pre-emptive
pharmacol genetic testing and I will be
very happy to answer any of your
questions so thank you very much for
your interest in your attention well
thank you dr. Bercow for that
informative presentation it is greatly
appreciated and before we get started on
the question answer session the
interactive part of our presentation
today I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found once again by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
remember we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can today as time allows
all right so
why don't we go ahead and jump on in
with our first question and the first
question asks do you have specific
health economic models that demonstrate
the value of reduced ABR du to
pre-emptive genotyping this is a very
good very good question we get this this
this is a very good question we we get
we get this question all all the time
and I think they're they're really good
examples out there but you're actually
showing this is a sweetie article I I
mentioned one of them a lot of other
studies are you know looking at this is
trying to look at this which actually
showed that pharmacogenetic testing
actually does reduce costs and is thus
economically make make sense and then
the really the question becomes is that
if you do this preemptively is the cost
for pre-emptive testing and which comes
and is associated with generating your
salts and translating and bringing this
to it into the medical record is this
really a cost effective and if as I said
and mentioned before the the cost for
genotyping you know if you if you look
at just a few years ago then what mostly
cost for one or two tests you know
finally if you just test one or two
genes that there was you know a
significant cost I mean we are now at
the level with the reduction in cost
what we see is that the cost what you
have we could test one two or even three
genes that's about the same cost but you
get if you do now with these new
technologies you through the pre-emptive
farm or if you do the genotyping
pharmacogenetic testing on a panel so I
think with that that really makes a
significant impact makes a significant
dent in this field and I think well
really build the the platform of the
foundation for bringing pre-emptive
pharmacogenetic testing to a more
broader
excellent thank you for that our second
question of the day asks do Indies fully
understand how to use pharmacogenetics
data and what tools are out there to
help them there's also a very good
question and you know I think I think
it's fair to say that pharmacogenetics
and interpretation of the results
genetic results how it translates to
doing the activity of a particular genes
how does then links to a particular drug
your physician would like to use is
really complex and there are lots of
drugs out there and a lot of teams out
there and so I think for for a number of
pretty common drugs where the
pharmacogenetic testing is well
established has been established for a
long time I think physicians really know
we know how to interpret this but the
data the data on the amount of data is
really largely cannula just memorize
this and so I think you know what's
really important here that we have
infrastructure and decision support and
so there are a number of initiatives out
there number of resources out there
which really help and guide towards that
and I think this is really growing and
asked the field is grown pharmacogenetic
testing these tools aren't developed I
think key component as I mentioned is
really decision support inside an EMR
this is where a physician or a nurse
process you know this is where the
decision is made what type of drug is
used and I think integrating the
decision support into the game are
providing this guidance accepted
guidance peer-reviewed you know support
based on peer reviewed support that's
really important the number of you know
groups out there which really you know
develop and drive this form and I so I
think that that is really you know what
see is an important component in the
implementation of pharmacogenetic
testing and thank you once again for
that answer um looks like we've got some
more questions our third question today
asks are there are many different
technologies for vgx testing can you
talk about the best uses or pros and
cons of each please yeah so and as you
say that a number of different platforms
out there and different vendors are
continuously developing new platforms so
we value an umber of different platforms
and and so their criteria ask how you
can decide what you want to do as I
mentioned in my presentation so if you
look at pharmacol scan that is a test
which generates a lot of data you're
looking at very comprehensively large
number of genes it takes about four to
five days to really process this so that
you need to take into account if you
order a test yeah I don't take
technologies out there which analyzed
less genes obviously comes with
advantage that you don't have to handle
a large data set and some of these
platforms actually can get the results
I'm not just in a few days that you can
get and the results may be in shorts
like a day or even in Toronto you can
you can measure this like in hours and
so that really depends on also on the
clinical needs some genetic tests you
need to have a very fast turnaround time
most of these tests actually didn't
analyze just a small number of variants
and then in other settings you have a
little bit more time you can do that
very comprehensive testing where you
have maybe and more you know a longer
Turner on time so I think that really
can i place it to this cost is also an
issue and intuitively one would think
that if you test one gene this might be
less expensive than you
as 10 or 15 genes but as I as I
mentioned before the changes in the
technologies what we have is no that
actually you know testing large number
of genes can be very competitive in
terms of pricing compared to two for
example analyzing just a smaller number
of genes so it also played a role is
like how comfortable healthcare
organizations in position are with
managing large data sets and so that
could speak for example for a you know
to choose a platform which has you know
a limited number number of arrogance but
turnaround time I think is a key
component which which drives this and
then me then the cost and then finally
and this should be busy standard is
obviously like with any test if your
component disk-like quality consistency
rep reducible a reproduce ability I
think are our key community components
and need to be evaluated in any platform
you like to choose okay our next
question asks why is pre-emptive
screening more attractive than focused
clinical methods
yeah so this is a good question as I
mentioned before their number of groups
a few years ago where you know really
caling they started pre-emptive
pharmacogenetic testing as a research
project and really thinking about this
we think about genetics in general and
we're moving towards you know more and
more genetic information how do we how
do we deal with this this pre-existing
genetic information and the integration
and how does that really translate into
into clinical decision support and so
you know from our point of view and if
you have time and in patients for
example you know we have I I likelihood
that over a lifetime over the next few
years that they have a high need to get
like different different drugs having
the genetic information available and
being able right at the time when you in
a position when we decide to prescribe a
particular drug if this information is
available having us and I'm busy
translating is nearly into the decision
support that should by all means should
have you know should make
pharmacogenetic testing pharmacogenetic
implementation much more easily
available implementable so we do really
see that if the data is there and if the
right decision support is there that
this really should make from a co
genetic implementation more acceptable
and really as I mentioned before the the
cost plays a role and the technology's
really advanced so much that not more
comprehensive testing is really in the
realm of like being very price
competitive compared to like a single
single cheats and I I certainly see that
there is much more interest now in
pre-emptive pharmacogenetic testing it's
also really the the idea of
of being able to have this data and
physicians being comfortable with
decision support which really drives
this and last but not least I think
patients are also getting more educated
about genetics and the information there
I was available in the opportunities
what about genetic offers and so I think
we certainly see I an interest from
patients as well excellent thank you for
that answer looks like we're going to
have time for at least two more
questions so let's begin have you seen
trends with regards to labs moving
increasingly towards pre-emptive
genotyping solutions yeah that's it this
is a very good question and I can
definitely say yes so when we started it
was more more of a challenge to really
convince people that you know the
concept of pre-emptive testing it is
still not no generally accepted that I
think would be would be to a struggle
statement but we have definitely a
significant interest from a number of
health care organizations Hospital
hospitals now yes the results and the
experiences of a number of the groups
who have to do a preemptive testing and
then this becomes available and so I
think there's really growing interest
there and and I think with the growing
interest areas really then also the
drive on the clinical testing side to
really expand on this and again the new
platforms the reduction in cost I think
that's also a really
important component into this so if you
if you you know need testing for let's
say your two chins you use a you know
more common very target platform and
that cost as much as the clinical test s
doing this whole panel very
comprehensive testing you get
substantially more data I think that
also drives to interest in this area and
this will be our last question of the
day before we wrap up have you heard
feedback to support that this approach
leads to a dr reduction that's a very
good very good question as well and it
really plays into the overall concept of
like this is cost-effective you know
what is really the outcome and yes we do
what else we have have evidence that the
pre-emptive data is actually in front of
genetic results which are a new medical
record are utilized are utilized
actually quite significantly that also
depends a little bit on the on the
patient population and but then clear
this is a very high utilization here and
and we do have evidence that having
pharmaprix state testing yourself
available really very directly
looks at verse events or really targeted
and brings or improves the way how how
for example physicians pick a particular
drug and so really reduces the time a
patient guy that gets to the right dose
or really fine steed the right drug for
ya for the particular disease so but
this is still intense area of research
and you know we clearly see that as this
approach it becomes more widely
available and that then the data you
know which looks not only cost
effectiveness but also that the outcome
and now benefits patient treatment that
does the body off of data and results
really will grow here excellent um thank
you once again for not only your time
today but your presentation dr. Bercow
um i would also like to thank our
sponsor at the metrics for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari 2017
and you will receive an email from
labyrinth alerting you when this webcast
we will be available for replay we
invite you it encourage you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live events thank
you so much for tuning in this is
christina saying goodbye from labyrinth
and we'll see you next time goodbye